I understand Josephine is standing by
with her next demo yes I'm over in the
other corner with Yvonne Tasha and I
called him dr. audio because he is the
go-to guy behind all the cool audio
engineering in xbox and it connects
thank you for bringing all your toys to
demo fast oh you're very welcome you
know when people hear about 3d they
usually think about visual but you're
talking about 3d audio and that's beyond
surround sound right it is beyond
because that all sound is actually
thought we have seven speakers but
they're in one plane and the 3d audio
means that we can render audio from up
from down from every single direction
Wow so use me as your guinea pig let's
see how this works all right okay let's
go I have to sit up here on this on this
chair because as I understand it they
have to take a model of my head and my
ears because why is it because my head
my ears actually determines how I here
I'll give you the Mike okay now what
happens is we're going to do two
dimensional scan of the head and general
generate the personalized spatially
hearing
I'm not supposed to talk which is kind
of hard but I was supposed to hold still
and look they're making like a almost a
clay model of my head because that is
going to affect how I here I know I have
no eyes there but it looks kind of cool
but now what is this going to allow us
to do so now we're trying to do is we
try to extract basic features from your
head so the width of your head the
height of your head the position of your
ears the position of your ear entrances
to width between ear canals and we're
using all that information to find a sub
set of measurements that we've taken
beforehand that matches your profile so
if you have a good experience in the
demo okay and so now I get to put on
headphones right okay don't put on these
headphones and the standard stereo
headphones with the gyroscope basically
on top we know what we have to play hold
on I gotta take out my earpiece yeah ok
so now I'm wearing these headphones this
part is gonna be much more exciting for
me than for you because I don't think
anyone else can hear anything but go
ahead what's wrong yeah but while you'll
be hearing a sound coming from each of
these objects that you see in front of
you and in your environment you'll think
it's coming from they're not from the
headphone to hear any sound coming from
the phones themselves ok can you start
it up for it that was David Johnston
also Microsoft Research who works with
Yvonne and now whoa I'm hearing this guy
talking do you not hear that listen to
this listen oh now the radios playing
dance party oh you can't hear that can
you all right see that's what it really
does sound like it's coming from there
right now the guys talking again and
what was that that was like a bird or
something
can you hear that it's the radio playing
yeah that is remarkably I just heard
this someone is knocking at the door and
it sounds like it oh and now the phone
the phone is ringing you can't hear but
it's an please that's what it sounds
like in my ear right now and now the
marimba is playing I want to hold the
mic up to it but obviously you're not
hearing is angry bird is talking to me
huh this is remarkable it really does
sound it really does sound like it now
everything this is a virtual concert
going on in my head oh my god Oh Yvonne
I need to talk to you I'm gonna take
this house that is really remarkable I
just want to ask about how this will be
used free diario so the tree diageo can
revolutionize and change even the simple
task of listening of stereo music
because the stereo music is designed to
be paid by two loudspeakers in front of
you when you put the two channels on the
headphones the audio scene is inside
your head with this technology we can
external eyes and play the stereo music
with the Algerian in front of you it is
trivial to acts around sound with 547
loudspeakers but the big hit is the game
yeah we can see it with gaming I can see
with movies what about people who can't
see people who are blind I could see how
that might be useful yes we actually are
engaged in a project with the biggest
charity in united kingdom called guide
dogs so they are working on a device
which is a wearable band across your
head with the headphones and they can
help blind people orient and navigate
through an environment by playing of
ritual sound markers so they can follow
the directions and to go from point A to
point
I know you can't talk about specific
products this is going in yet but I can
see a lot of applications thank you very
much even touch them and it's also big
hit here at demo fest Chris you gotta
try this out